all right whoo it's Wow it's very cold
one two one
uh this is a Manman Mike I've known him
since the third grade
we're college buddies met in college
we have roomed together for various
times over five years hopping around
various apartments discs Kevin and I
know each other for about one year and a
half yeah yeah you're not I'm not a long
time but it's been a good it's been a
good two years if I were to give a
reason why I think Kyle's my friend it's
because I think Kyle just gets me it's
all right here you know so I hear mental
connections this is a draw right like we
take a step and then we shoot each other
all right move its wow it's very cold
one two ha ha ha
I should have laughs how's it going you
didn't give me the full up-and-down
system regular just good-looking person
I'd say it's a 10 you know he's got a 10
out of 10 you don't see the hips often
yeah hipline oh man no wonder it's all
the ladies right what can I say oh well
you guys can see this at home
interesting uh uh hair dude that's cool
my razor broke I'm a grower I'm
definitely a now I'm a super grower I
got mold set I should get checked out
you're good naked man did you get naked
man try it out more ah okay good man
oh yeah is my uncle's should we do a
helicopter alfredo yeah yeah I mean I
feel like you do it's so moving
oh no I'm I I might already be
repressing this okay I don't know if
they have couples therapy for just
friends but they should I feel like
things are just gonna keep going on the
path that they were on which is you know
straight to forever man
I also feel like um
Kyle's judged me glad we did this
yeah it's cool let's cool Oh Dodger is
it I hope that I lost my best friend
forever look if you know someone well
you like have an idea of their penis in
your head that like doesn't even have to
match up you've already thought about my
penis I mean I think well I'm thinking
mommy abstract helicopter brain yeah